[Music]
my name is Frank Canelo I'm the
owner/operator best pizza here in
Williamsburg Brooklyn but basically just
a regular New York's like shop located
you know in the middle of the block
sandwiched in between a church in a
school pretty sleepy block I was born
and raised in Brooklyn and Bensonhurst
my goal was always to have a
neighborhood period and I wanted to do
it very much in the style of the
pizzeria that I grew up going to well we
did the pizza here I wanted to keep it
limited and focused and pay homage to
all of those slices that were kind of a
special side to the Brooklyn it's three
slices that you would always see is the
Sicilian slice the square the regular
round slice and then you had this white
place so we got the pizza slice so the
white pie is made very similar to all of
our pizzas here we take one of our dough
and we basically open it up so it's
about 20 inches we put it on the wood
peel and then from there we start
layering it and the layering process is
really important we take a little bit of
water and sort of with the pastry
brushes go around the crust on the dough
be able to put the sesame seeds around
so during the baking process the sesame
seeds really stay on after that we start
to take the mozzarella cheese that we
make in-house we grated ourselves and
then we put sort of like just a thin
layer of mozzarella cheese because a
couple cheese components so we try to
keep their ratios and even as possible
after the first layer of mozzarella
cheese we take our ricotta cheese and we
started dollop raghava on top of the
mozzarella around the pie once that's
there I teach my guys so that's a follow
of a dollar serve ragazzo without
carmelized onions we top it off with a
little bit of grated pecorino cheese
my family's Sicilian so we try to take
as many nods from Sicilian cuisine this
so we bake it in a wood-fired oven like
the rest of our pizzas and when it comes
out we finish it with some more pecorino
cheese it's like raw and it has
definitely a different flavor to it and
then a little bit of parsley on top and
I think the parsley adds freshness and
kind of liven it up a little bit our
goal is just always kind of off-duty a
traditional by the slice pizza but make
sure that we're really structure the
traditions in the grating reading
there's something special about the
white pie it just seems to be one of
those pies that people keep coming back
[Music]